jacques monory bonsoir je ne faisais la
même question comme pause sans arrêt sur
les costumes gris et chemise lacoste
depuis combien de temps tu portes ce
chapeau
je peux de cheveux ça se trouve très
très longtemps j'essaie perdu très cher
est-ce que c'est jamais débauche peugeot
récent entretien poussette va très bien
en tous les cas tant côté thriller tu as
fait beaucoup de frayeurs dans tes
peintures
est ce que tu es prêt pour l'interview
pinceau mousse ça va se fera pour rayer
une préparation
[Applaudissements]
mais
tu as commencé en plein milieu de
l'abstrait comment ça s'est passé quand
est arrivée en sens pas de l'abstrait à
une époque où l'art abstrait était au
summum j'ai vu l'un des sites web
puisque si on n'est pas là mais non
alain donnât ici alors on va essayer de
parler de ton travail comment ça se
passe si tu prends des photos soit des
photos personnelles soient des photos
collectif sur des photos des photos des
archives comme dans le temps vous allez
des croquis ou ou des dessins et puis tu
laitue l'école tu les utilisent tel et
tulle et projette et après tu passes une
couleur par dessus c'est ça ça c'est
sûrement très schématique mais je vais
essayer d'expliquer vraiment ce que
c'est moi qui consiste alors la couleur
que tu passes par dessus ça l'entente et
et du bleu qui un jour tu as laissé
tomber les bleus pourquoi ce qu'on
parlait du bleu mono rien tu sais ça oui
le bleu etc et une protection très très
très bien très pratique on peut montrer
des choses extrêmement dur et qu'on ne
pourrait pas sur sa laisse et c'était
avec des couleurs naturelles le mettant
dans le bleu ça ça distincts si c'est
tout à fait pratique mais au bout d'un
temps je connais cette foule de trucs
trop bien
j'en ai et alors tu es choisit quoi le
le jaune le rose en plus du bloc
technique des expositions les plus
connus bon ben ça a été effectivement
les images incurable après les opéras
glacée en 75 c'est là que je t'ai connu
l'époque de façade
et puis en 77 technicolor et tu exposes
squash et le long en ce moment ça
s'appelle le peintre et ses symboles
carrément et ce sont des singes laisse
les pins de fonds nous laissons bah oui
on essaye de reproduire la réalité
suivante oui non là ça va tu serais qui
s'était pas jacques monory comme un
malaise en août comme être humain c'est
au choix
alors sachez qu'aucune idée franchement
qu'elle me dirai quel animal du ve est
je fonds à vous retrouver majoritaire
dans les films policiers par hasard à ce
que j'aurais pu être un oui ça j'ai
failli mal tourner la tête vous êtes
écrit un polar mais comment jason bach
c'est une relation d'un voyage en
californie d'influencé bar qui a été
influencé par qui parce que maintenant
tu affluence plutôt les autres médias
français par kyodo
pas assez quand j'ai commencé à avoir
conscience de ce que je voulais faire le
potard secret alors je fais partie ce
mouvement
tu es copier copier - un petit peu dans
son coin ce plaisir beaucoup
d'illustrateurs et moi je trouve qu'il
ya un moment il disait que ça allait
beaucoup d'illustrateurs quittons copier
non dans la pub dans la presse concéder
des sous monory non oui un peu quelques
femmes et c'est assez logique parce que
moi je trouve ça tout à fait normal moi
je prenais des choses dans la publicité
alors on leur pique je trouve ça très
bien ouais ça l'écosystème oui et tu
tues mais qu'en même temps pour faire un
tableau
c'est par exemple en rentrant l'appui
dit tiens je vais en faire un petit à
petit j'ai beaucoup de mal c'est un
grand deux mètres sur deux jeux mais je
vais facilement pour l'exécuter jeunesse
facilement 15h15 heure oui ça va tu le
vends combien mais pour le politologue 6
mai mais tu sais que ça vaut combien
meneur et aujourd'hui je veux qu'on
mettra dans mon salon de deux mètres sur
deux ça doit valoir
120 me faut s'en sont de 10 mille francs
de l'heure ça fait 10 mn
c'est vraiment bien j'aurais jamais cru
je vais déjà les travées de travail tu
fais partie des pentes qui servent la
peinture qui se servent de la peinture à
moi je me tiendrai vaincu mais mais mais
la peinture elle est très mystérieuse
parce qu'à la fin elle elle est très
intense et elle finit par servir de vos
si on peut dire si je vais rester une
définition toit d'un dictionnaire des
pannes ce serait quoi j'ai pas du
capital un gel de définition du
dictionnaire des pins
bah c'était celui qui était le plus près
du cinéma
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu